[Music]
after the scene I immediately grab the
facehugger I have in my garage and went
to the cave in my backyard to see if one
of its tentacles could get hung up on a
stalactite in this manner I was really
good at hitting my head against the
stalactite and even after several rubs I
was turned on by the stalactite but I
could not get the facehugger to wrap its
tentacle around it geez does Morty only
have four top teeth why have not noticed
this before four which makes you wonder
how Rick even let this happen based on
how this episode progresses he's clearly
very aware of the alien movies and
facehuggers in general so he should have
been at the very least putting those
lessons to use that nobody from
Prometheus learned about touching
strange substances out in the wild it
was too wet you don't get to tell me
what to look at I've seen your pornhub
account man you couldn't wait to take
the leap from things you shouldn't look
at as a matter of survival to shaming
Morty for his porn profile could you not
to mention invading his privacy and
that's your grandson man you looked up
his account to see what turns him on
also later we find out that while Morty
told Rick not to look at the egg he was
just as enamoured with the egg as Rick
was oh if I've been watching one of
those Rick and Morty integrated ads this
whole time I thought this was the
episode in this after I wrote so many
sins on that Pringles ad last week it's
not exactly an incentive feeling egg in
your stomach no glass-half-full if Rick
is basing all his information on alien
then he should know that Cain didn't
feel the egg in his stomach until it was
way too late so sounds like your glass
might be half full of glub glub Jesus
Christ who the [ __ ] was I I guess Rick
immediately subscribed to his parasites
channel as soon as he saw it or he took
this phone from one of the guards who
clearly didn't like Rick and therefore
wouldn't be a subscriber to his channel
did did I at least sell out and sell
vitamins or something no Wendy's but
close enough I did this you and the
amazing technology you both brought us I
get that the summer reveal is a surprise
for us later on in the episode but there
is no reason the face-hugging parasites
wouldn't be mentioning her here since
she is the one most responsible for the
changes in their society is there more
nope nope I guess that's it just don't
glory so earth so are these creatures
called lures oh is
so what they call morty wears blurs Oh a
verb because I'll be God glory if I can
glory so I'll with the glories of these
facehuggers our glorying about are they
like the Smurfs why haven't you blinked
for 20 minutes and why doesn't your
mouth move when you talk they're just
now noticing this these creatures
clearly have gloss over brains jeez
you'd think Rick would have better duct
tape than this and that magic lab Cody
wears why are they keeping the
facehugger masks if they're fleeing the
planet it's as if Rick knows they might
forget something and have to come back
later and use them again rich tiny
spaceship apparently can take flight
even with something like 20 times
heavier attached to it honestly I'm
proud of us for not totally would have
been cheap congratulating yourself on
not making a 911 joke which actually by
definition is still itself a 911 Joe
also I'm wondering why during this
entire rampage Rick hasn't been wearing
his seat belt except this one time here
just before they see the knot World
Trade Center and then when it comes back
he's not wearing it even though it's the
same background same framing same
everything did they animate multiple
takes pretending that the actor who
plays Rick had to go to the bathroom at
some point and he forgot to put a seat
belt back on so you did a 911 almost we
went with a Pearl Harbor we're pretty
classy in a moment of Michael Bay versus
Charlie Sheen I do you think Rick and
Morty made the right choice but not sure
it's a moment to be proud of I've been
getting into beekeeping lately there's
something wrong with that wrong with
beekeeping no but there is something
wrong with how long it's taking you to
slice those pancakes who even uses a
knife on a pancake
are they steak pancakes I mean what the
glory so I don't sequel it's called
integrity then please explain
interdimensional cable - so Rick's wrist
watch thingy is saying that summer is
underground in that's it how unhelpful
is this locator thing does it even have
directions Empress is everything all
right
seize them I don't get why Rick can't
put that shield around them again and
bring out some other weapon that he
probably has in that lab coat but shows
got to fill 22 minutes somehow I guess
[Music]
I'm just gonna call this Davos XR maka
not because why does either of them have
a harmonica and it just so happens to be
the facehuggers weakness why did you
tell your minions to seize them you've
been on enough Rick and Morty adventures
to know that Rick would have gotten you
out of here without having to come up
with some wacky plan to escape
you're in a cape summer how bad could it
be no bad story ends with a cape Justice
League does Rick can we listen to
something else first off people listen
to anything surrounded by other people
who don't want to listen to it without
headphones I'm talking to you dude at
the airport on speakerphone and woman
watching YouTube with the volume turned
to 85 decibels you know who you are
second off why doesn't morty have his
own device with headphones
i'm just saying they're currently in a
spaceship i'm assuming the technology
exists it's a toothpick i'm a toothpick
ER now get used to it God are you that
desperate for a thing this show is
experiencing a self-awareness crisis
from the previous episode that has
spilled over into this episode
everything is being introduced as a
thing and someone has to comment on it
why couldn't the episode do something
where she simply needed the toothpick
because this toothpick is crucial to the
plot it's the only reason why face
huggers can't grab her later it is my
thing just like yours is dying alone how
can die alone be a thing a thing is
something you do often dying alone is
something you do once maybe twice if
you're a Gemini how long have you been
hatched 30 seconds I've been alive 7
minutes I'm getting heavy me 6 vibes
from these things so all you do is live
half an hour eggs and die yes we love
Stephen King presents Rick and Morty's
dreamcatcher okay listen to me but I
vote you don't do that and who's up for
changing things around here so wait all
these other face huggers that have been
around long enough to know what their
purpose in life is just accept summer
suggestion with no questions asked and
they're able to get everyone in town on
board with that plan how do these things
suck the egg back into their bodies
so why do they do it they obviously
don't know who summer is so they don't
know why they should follow her also
summer seems to be without her toothpick
all of a sudden which i think is unwise
considering that's the reason she was
considered a god in the first place
okay there's at least a couple details
in this episode that I love the pencils
and gums stuck in the ceiling and the
facehugger paper dolls in the classroom
honestly summer I can't thank you enough
it's really weird that this society
deifies summer but they don't put images
of her everywhere and give all the glory
to Steve slash Morty yeah I know there
are groups of fans out there who have
been dying for Rick and Morty to make
out it's probably the number one
requested thing on all the chat boards
but this is one of those things that
shows do where they play on that thing
that you really want and it doesn't
count it's like in the x-files movie
when molder does CPR on Scully and the
filmmakers were able to tease that their
lips touch or when James Earl Jones's
voice comes out of Maggie and one of
those Simpsons Halloween specials anyway
I'm glad they got the burning will they
or won't they question out of the way in
season four now maybe they can bring in
Kirstie Alley now that they're showing
this part again I've got to say this is
the MC Escher of animated ex machina see
how that does that tentacle get around
the right side of that stalactite when
Morty walks to the left of it it's not
like the tentacle is in a loop formation
it's tightly attached to his face and we
shall drive away from here and die she's
trying to escape with her family my time
to shine is there something missing from
this episode in the first part of the
episode that causes the conflict the
missile that they were supposed to send
to the earth was going to send a bunch
of facehuggers right their message may
have been peace but they were still
going to send parasites to a bunch of
unwilling hosts but before we get a
chance to see what it was going to do
Rick throws it into a building and it
explodes this is the most confusing part
of the episode because it's never
spelled out what that missile was going
to do when it got to the planet and it
seems like Rick and Morty were going to
have to kill a lot of these things to
escape anyway so it doesn't really
matter if they were peaceful or not so
why is he apologizing about kill
how is this guy still alive hasn't
armonica music reached him yet I was
working with a lot just let me listen to
the podcast next time but the podcast
had nothing to do with why they ended up
on this world can we just relax and
maybe watch some interdimensional cable
we don't need to try so hard you know
let's just take it easy and riff you
know I for one will be very happy when
you guys leave the Being John Malkovich
stage and just go ahead and make an
episode without so much self reference I
mean it's kind of cute like your dad
keeps bees what the heck was that is
that some sort of American Beauty parody
Jerry's beekeeping makes him attractive
to teenage girls a few bad eggs led by
one little egg in particular I have spit
in the face of that generosity we're
saying goodbye to your favorite
cinemasins merch designs forever
because I'm not a heartless bastard like
some people think I discounted the out
of the store for a couple weeks links
below or at cinema since calm release
the Kraken glory to glory so totally
welcome to Costco
I don't sequel it's called integrity
sequels suck by definition alone they're
inferior films ready to form Voltron
activate interlock no no that no this is
like torture no III hate being in my car
robo-dog Stratos